[Music]
when you look at this what do you see
to me this is one of the most beautiful
fascinating
and frustrating things i've ever seen
that's because i'm a mathematician
and these hypnotizing curly cues have
haunted people like me for
150 years what we're looking at is a
glimpse of the riemann hypothesis
it's one of the most important if not
the most important unsolved problems
in all of mathematics you may have heard
about the riemann hypothesis because
it's one of the millennium problems of
the clay institute
what that means is that the person who
solves it not only achieves immortality
in mathematics
but also wins a 1 million prize
but there are other reasons to care
about the enigma that is the riemann
hypothesis
if the hypothesis is true it would solve
a mystery as old as math itself
that is the mystery of the prime numbers
countless theorems in fields as far
apart as cryptography and quantum
physics
assume that the riemann hypothesis is
true which means that we have a lot
riding
on this single unproven statement so
what is it
what is the riemann hypothesis why has
the search for a proof
become something of a holy grail for
mathematicians and what do these strange
curly cues
have to do with all of this my name is
alex conterovich and i'm a professor of
mathematics
i'll serve as your guide as we explore
the riemann hypothesis
in order to build a somewhat
sophisticated understanding of this
hypothesis
what i'm going to try to do is mention
some slightly advanced concepts
now you don't need an advanced degree in
mathematics to go on this journey with
me
what i'm going to do is try to lay the
groundwork step by step in a visual and
intuitive way
so to begin let's venture into the
chaotic and elusive universe
of prime numbers
this is factor city where the primes are
literally the building blocks of all
numbers
now every whole number is a building and
it's been constructed
out of its primes the one-story houses
are exactly the primes now thanks to the
ancient greek euclid of alexandria
we know that the one-story buildings
keep going on forever
if you can walk that far but
depending on where you're standing you
might want to know how many one story
buildings do you see around you
[Music]
this is what we want to understand about
the prime numbers and what we currently
don't
you see the prime numbers seem to just
pop up randomly among the natural
numbers
all the way out to infinity
[Music]
in the late 1700s mathematicians were
really starting to wonder
whether it was possible to predict the
places where primes would appear
now a teenage boy named carl friedrich
daus was especially obsessed with taming
the primes
he calculated massive tables of primes
going all the way up to 3 million
and looked for patterns we can see the
data that gauss collected on the prime
numbers by using something we'll call
the prime counting function
the graph of that function will show us
exactly where the prime numbers appear
as the numbers get bigger and bigger so
the graph stays flat until you hit a
prime
and at that point it jumps up by one
here's what the graph looks like
out to 10 and out to 100
and now out to 3 million as far as gauss
went
at this scale those bumps we saw early
on have smoothed out
leaving a pretty pleasant curve when
gauss looked at this data he asked
himself
is there some other function that i know
that has pretty much
the same graph now as luck would have it
at around the same time gauss was also
playing around with logarithm functions
you might remember that a logarithm is a
function that undoes exponentiation
much in the same way as division undoes
multiplication
what gauss noticed was that the graph of
something called the logarithmic
integral function that's a function
whose slope is 1 over log x
looked suspiciously similar to the graph
of the prime counting function
here's what they look like together you
can see why gauss made the connection
at this scale they're so close you can't
even distinguish them
to understand what the slope of one over
log x has to do with prime numbers
let's pay another visit to factor city
what gauss imagined
was that if you're standing at address x
and you look left and you look right
the proportion of one story buildings
that is primes
that you would see around you is roughly
the same
as one over log x this suspicion became
known as gauss's conjecture
after gauss formulated this conjecture
his student bernard riemann went on to
do something absolutely incredible with
it
but to understand what riemann did we
first have to go back in time a little
bit
to meet someone else
this is leonard euler one of the world's
first
students of calculus later on in his
life he wrote many influential textbooks
and standardized the modern math
notation that we still use to this day
if you've ever written something in
standard function notation you know like
y equals f x well you can thank or
perhaps blame
leonard euler in euler's time
mathematicians were trying to understand
the general structure of infinite series
what that means is you're trying to add
up an infinite sequence of numbers like
one a half a quarter an eighth and so on
forever
sometimes that total sum is a finite
number
which we then call a limit
if a series has a limit we would say
that the series itself
is convergent in this series our limit
is two
on the other hand if we were to add
let's say one plus one plus one plus one
plus one forever
well that sum would eventually become
larger than any finite number
and so we would say that that series is
divergent
sometimes it can be rather tricky to
tell if a given series converges or not
so for example this series which is
called the harmonic series
turns out actually diverges even though
the terms themselves are getting smaller
and smaller
this is really rather not obvious and
takes some mathematical gymnastics to
verify
[Music]
now what about this series the sum of 1
over the squares
of all the positive integers it wasn't
hard for mathematicians to show that
this series does indeed converge
but the question was what is the exact
limit
euler shout to mathematical super
stardom when he saw this problem
what he realized and proved is that the
limit is pi
squared over six isn't that weird what
in the world does pi
have to do with the squares well that's
another story for another time
so full of adrenaline from his early
victory euler kept going he found the
limits of the sum of one over the
positive integers to the fourth power
and to the sixth power and to the eighth
power now let's try to study all these
series at once
let's write s for that exponent when we
do this we define
what's called the zeta function in other
words zeta of two is the sum of
one over the squares and zeta four is
the sum of one over the fourth powers
and so on
euler proved that all of these converge
but only when
s is greater than one but here's where
things got
really interesting euler discovered that
the zeta function could be expressed as
an infinite product
one for each prime number of an infinite
series
here's what you do for each prime number
you add up one
over all the powers of that prime to the
s
if you multiply all those series over
all the prime numbers
you get the zeta function
[Music]
euler's discovery hinted at an intimate
connection between the zeta function
and prime numbers but it would take
another hundred years for the full
meaning to reveal itself
and that's when our friend bernard
riemann would make a major breakthrough
in prime number theory
and that breakthrough would potentially
allow us for the first time
to understand the profound mysteries of
prime numbers
so riemann he's born in 1826
in modern-day germany he's an absolutely
spectacular
and innovative prolific mathematician
and among other things his novel
approach to geometry
actually lays the mathematical
groundwork for einstein's theory of
relativity
riemann was also one of the founders of
complex analysis which is a branch of
math that studies functions with complex
inputs and outputs
and he realized he might have something
new to say if he studied from that point
of view
euler's zeta function
you might remember that the square of
any real number is positive
so 2 squared is 4 but negative 2 squared
is also four so there is no number whose
square is negative one
it turns out that it's really rather
useful for mathematicians to have a
number whose square is negative one
so what did we do we just made one up we
called it
i for imaginary so whenever you see i
squared what that means is you should
replace it with negative 1.
this means that any real multiple of i
like 3i or 2i
these are all imaginary cousins of the
real numbers
when you take combinations of real
numbers and imaginary numbers you get
something we call a complex number
complex numbers might look like two
numbers but they're actually just one
number expressed as two parts
the real part and the imaginary the
thing is these imaginary and complex
numbers they aren't imaginary at all
they're just the natural extension of
our usual number system
from one dimension to two they're
plotted in what we call the complex
plane
with the real part going left to right
and the imaginary part up to down
once you have these complex numbers you
can study complex functions
that is functions with inputs and
outputs living in the complex plane
and so armed with the power of complex
analysis riemann opened up a whole new
perspective
on the world of mathematics riemann
wondered
what would happen if you allowed the
zeta function to take complex inputs
that is he allowed s to be a complex
number
so let's take the complex exponent s
equals two plus three i
for example we can plug it into zeta
and the function will look like this now
if we add each term
one at a time in the complex plane we
can see how the series begins to spiral
beautifully
so riemann had successfully accomplished
what he set out to do
he extended the zeta function to the
complex plane
but just like euler riemann found that
the function only converged
when the real part of s was greater than
one
now riemann had a brilliant idea he
realized it was possible to extend the
zeta function to the rest of the complex
plane
riemann used a technique called analytic
continuation which allowed him to break
open the hidden potential of the zeta
function
now analytic continuation is an advanced
concept in complex analysis
but it's possible to make sense of it
intuitively you can think of it as a
logical problem-solving method to extend
the domain of a function
in order for riemann to fill in the
missing part of the domain
in euler's data function he had to
create a brand new function
this function would take the same values
as the zeta function where they both
converge
but it had to make sense everywhere else
on the plane too
so the secret to analytic continuation
is that there are really
two functions at work at once one is the
original zeta function
which has limited scope but the other is
this new function
the riemann zeta function which extends
beyond the domain that euler defined
remember this now we can take a closer
look at it and finally begin to
understand its mysteries
you see when riemann extended the domain
of the zeta function something kind of
amazing happened
in the new territory that riemann
uncovered suddenly the zeta function can
be seen crossing through the origin
what that means is for some inputs the
zeta function evaluates to zero
we call these places the zetas zeros
some of the zeta zeros are easy to
explain when you input
a negative even integer the zeta
function equals zero
but we don't need to worry about these
so-called trivial zeros it's the
non-trivial zeros that we need to talk
about
these other zeta zeros exhibit a very
compelling pattern
and that pattern is the central theme of
the riemann hypothesis
all of the non-trivial zeros lie inside
a single region called the critical
strip
this is where the real part of s is
between 0 and 1.
riemann proved that there are infinitely
many zeros to be found
in this critical strip but here is the
most important takeaway from riemann's
groundbreaking 1859 paper
riemann hypothesized that all of the
non-trivial zeros
will lie not just somewhere in the strip
but on a single vertical line
smack dab in the middle we call this the
critical line
which is where the real part of s is
exactly one half
this is exactly the hypothesis that now
bears riemann's name
and the million dollar bounty
now at this point you might be wondering
why does the location of these
non-trivial zeros matter
and what does all of this have to do
with prime numbers i don't blame you
let me show you exactly why riemann's
hypothesis is of such profound
consequence to number theory
and let me do so by sharing riemann's
final discovery
remember gauss's prime counting function
from the very beginning of the video
well for technical reasons we're going
to slightly modify it right now but
don't worry
we'll preserve the essence of the
function instead of stepping up by
1 every time we see a new prime number
which we'll call p
let us step up by log p and we'll also
do the same when we encounter p
squared np cubed and p to the fourth and
so on
so let me try to explain why we're doing
all of this riemann found a surprising
connection between this modification of
gauss's conjecture and
his new zeta function he discovered a
wave that corresponds to the zeta
function at s equals one
and showed that gauss's conjecture would
follow if only
you could show that this wave was the
fundamental frequency which means that
it more and more closely approximates
the prime counting function
as they both grow to infinity so here's
what the prime counting function looks
like
with that wave that riemann discovered
riemann realized that the zeta zeros
were exactly what he needed to adjust
this straight line
to match the jagged counting function
every time he added a zeta zero it
contributed a harmonic
here's what the first harmonic looks
like when we add it on
it ever so gently tries to smooth out
the wiggles of the modified prime
counting function
what happens when we plug in the second
zeta zero little better right
what about the first 10 or the first 30
or the first 60 you get the point
riemann was able to rigorously prove
that if you add up all the harmonics of
the zeta zeros
all infinitely many of them you get a
perfect match to gauss's modified prime
counting function
so riemann's hypothesis showed that the
distribution of prime numbers
can in fact be predicted the location of
prime numbers is profoundly connected to
the location of these non-trivial zeta
zeros
this means that if the riemann
hypothesis is indeed true
it would tell us everything we could
possibly have a right to know about the
distribution of prime numbers
needless to say riemann was unable to
prove the full hypothesis
in other words neither he nor anyone
since has been able to show that
every single non-trivial zeta zero lies
on that critical line
at one point a massive computing project
checked over one billion
non-trivial zeta zeros every single day
the computer was looking for a single
errant
zero if found just one then the riemann
hypothesis would fall apart
[Music]
in the end of the 10 trillion zeros that
the computer checked
every single one was on the critical
line
but if you see a pattern holding again
and again and again it's still
impossible for machines to check it all
the way to infinity
so brute force computation will never
resolve the riemann hypothesis
that means there's still only one way to
be sure of it and it's the same way that
the ancient greeks did their math
rigorous absolute mathematical proof
[Music]
you